how are you rich DP how you been man i'm
good i'm curious when you get ticket
requests do people feel like you have
tickets with NFL games oh gosh yes yo
you say and passes parking i like how
people have a problem a I thanks for the
tickets but damn parking like a parking
pass they wanted they want an
experienced and it's not just tickets
it's the whole you know it's a package I
you guys can you must get that to toad
an all the time get that I've gotten it
all ready for the world series where
people go yoy you go to Wrigley all the
time you know people and I go I don't
have any tickets well it's not just that
they probably expect that you again it's
the experience it'll be you and kerry
wood and such yes doin karaoke somewhere
you know and in an apartment building
that you know the players used to crash
in after the games that sort of
experience i'm sure but also at the
Super Bowl people will ask like you got
extra tickets like I I have no I don't
have extra ticket all right I'll say
something like oh I just gave it away
like five minutes ago I had four tickets
and all that sorry about that right but
you you know you know the family I
married into you know my wife and
they're all New Englanders so I kind of
have every other year built an excuse
that all my tickets have gone to my
in-laws because the Patriots make it
once every 2-3 years and i'm already
getting ready to use that as an excuse
for Houston this year well they probably
think well could you could we go to
dinner with Tom Brady I mean you know it
right I'll bring McGinest maybe brewski
if I'm lucky yeah I mean but I guess you
know we're fortunate to do what we do
for a living it's interesting though I'm
still staring at my phone to see people
call to get tickets to tonight's Jaguars
nobody's calling I'm what I'm wondering
if maybe I've got bad reception I'm just
looking for the voicemail to light up
you know looking forward to that maybe
you get like a 45-42 shoot out tonight
I'll be great you know but in to justify
if I'm a UH the the sunday night game
this past week to me I loved it okay I
loved that game and I know was
unwatchable for a lot of people with the
penalties that were thrown but you know
with it flags they got thrown off
offensive holding every other play but
to me a game like that was so intense
and every down mattered and then there
was a little bit of a hot mess at the
end that you know what I loved like Al
Michaels call was so spot-on and
Collinsworth could do nothing but tackle
as house go pulled it left you know I
mean I love the whole thing but if that
was a Thursday night game people would
be saying oh gosh you're right there's
too much football this is terrible you
know any guys are tired it's too much I
mean so it is a little bit of a double
standard when it comes to thursday night
and tonight i am hoping for a little bit
of a shootout Mariota has got some
obvious game bortles has been a thorough
disappointment this year and you know
and that that division is up for grabs I
mean that's all I've got right now
that's all I I still think that if you
get to a point where you're ending up
with a tie then you just have a shootout
and it's just you kicked from would it
be 35 competition no you go 35 and then
he goes 35 and then you go for tea and
then he goes 40 and then you go 45 and
he goes 4500 you mean just a kicker yeah
kicking condo oh my gosh yeah just off a
shootout and can Bobby Wagner jumps ok
trying hocus that make it more
interesting I mean that I was incredible
I honest did you like that game because
I I really loved it I just wanted I
wanted I wanted an ending I wanted
somebody to or lose because it's so
important in that division and I I just
whoever was going to win you know I
wanted to have it completed and it
always feels like the
why do we stay up for this right and
also for those like us in our profession
now it forces us to do with math later
on in the season and see we don't want
to do math you know and its way it'll be
one of those things to where he forget
that there was that tie and talking
about the division and it is it is
important though you know I guess that
Seattle didn't lose um you'd rather not
lose a road game but i just thought
again it was just terrific defense on
display every 1st down mattered david
johnson was a man in that game and and
and the seattle defense proved to be I
think as good as it was in its super
bowl season I really love that but there
was definitely a double standard that
Afghanistan was a Thursday night people
would be complaining he's rich eisen
from the NFL network and the Rich Eisen
show you can see on audience channel 239
DIRECTV what happened to the Jaguars I
thought this was the year where they at
least took out that next step and then
maybe the following year we looked at
them as a playoff contender yes there
were two bandwagons this year that were
you know asking people to get off for
future bandwagons and it's that one and
Oakland and Oakland has proven to be a
really good team taking the next step
and Jacksonville's taking a step back
the to Allen's the Allen brothers have
been non factors you know Chris Ivory's
injury I guess with that a running game
with TJ Yeldon that was supposed to be
something but bortles is regressed
there's no two ways about it the defense
that's chock full of all these top draft
choices I guess or just keep being
thrown back out there on the field too
much and it just adds up to a dreadful
record they could be winless right now
and have been just brutal there's no
other way to put it and Gus Bradley's
gig one would believe is on the line I
don't even know if you could say that
about tonight you there's an argument
you could make that tonight with a mini
by coming after this that they
might make a move are the Lions the Cubs
in the NFL what do you mean by that that
they haven't won mmm there's that
because the grounds one in the 60s they
won championships yeah the Jets have
their name of year yeah I mean if it all
goes one that's a good one the Lions
would definitely be that I'm just going
in my head right now because the bills
even had their championship years in a
dynasty which I definitely would call
them a dynasty wow wow chargers are up
there too but the Lions are are one of
those kind of restore the roar years and
had I mean would Bernie that with them
would would would Barry Sanders be there
Ernie Banks right you know I'm trying to
continue this analogy yeah I like it
they are but still even if the Lions
made the Super Bowl I don't think you'd
see the same passion and the action from
their fan base as well as the rest of
the country kind of rooting for them but
that's as close as you can get I think
that's a good one but the reason why you
have this love affair with the Cubs is
because the WGN that you were able to
before the proliferation of baseball
cable that you had WGN and yet WTBS
those those two channels made you a
Braves fan or Cub fan and you could be
in any other state and to have that so
everybody knows your story not everybody
knows their bright line story yeah
you're right Marshall Faulk talks all
the time growing up in New Orleans highs
a Braves fan because of TBS you Kurt
Warner is a huge Cubs fan living next
door in Iowa and I think WGN had a lot
to do with that and also you know look
Harry Caray the you know on WGN by the
way um a great spot with hairy a couple
days ago on your show dan let's firstly
the principal him get you the great get
frizzies Ouija board whatever whatever
you did to hell him that was great where
he
called and talking about the beechwood
aged spot hell that was oh that was
great but now I have asked Fritz you to
track down people who are are actually
dead and he and he did try to get ahold
of him he never gives up who was it
fritzy I Sugar Ray yeah Robinson invited
Sugar Ray Robinson and his widow
unfortunately told me that this was now
possible unavailable I'm definitely yes
unavailable not available in na you got
back yeah family can you do another then
I pushed in doing the third I'll event
yes not available ok out of fail cell
surgery it was a great spot the other
day that was that was great thanks have
fun tonight as always and sell it man
like DP seller hey let me ask you this
question so I have a couple minutes here
all right ha alright next week thursday
night football moves to the family at at
NBC dan and i look forward to seeing you
out there in tampa florida young I'm not
part of the team there yeah hold on a
minute yeah because you know a bob will
be there al Chris yep yep all the great
ones Tony and Rodney yep um how did how
did how did the hall pass come about Dan
how did that one I just said look I
can't leave this audience I can't leave
the dance and you're just gonna have to
get somebody to fill in for me so they
said okay all right they'll find uh they
actually they didn't argue much they go
okay all right fine we'll get Bob Wow
yeah well that's it so they go to they
go to the past I don't think they went
to the bullpen but oh yeah Bobby I mean
tango yeah we got the whole crews
Enrico's right is he he but he's doing I
don't know just a part of it right I
don't know hi I think they're sending
everybody their men in blazers they're
sending doc Emrick I mean everybody
everybody's going but me so so when Otto
Bolden shows up after Matt Lauer the
only guy not showing up his Billy Bush
that's the only guy but he did ask if he
could be a part of the program but he
I'm gonna be my word well I'll say hi to
everybody for you all right we'll have
fun tonight all right thank you rich
that's rich eisen the NFL network the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience